[Música]
vamos a Washington con nuestro
corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez con sin
duda alguna una de las noticias del día
Cristóbal el FBI arrestó a un joven de
apenas 21 años a quien se señala de ser
el responsable de la filtración de
documentos más grave en Estados Unidos
en la última década desde el caso de
Edward snowden que se sabe de dicha
divulgación
con apenas 21 años había entrado a la
guardia aérea nacional a los 19 años y
hasta hacía muy poco estaba ya en
contacto y manejando información
confidencial que empezó a compartir con
un grupo de cerca de 20 o 30 jóvenes de
su edad en la red social esta red social
es la que usan jóvenes Gamers para
comunicarse entre ellos pues en este
grupo empezó él a compartir esta
información y uno de estos integrantes
de este grupo fue el que filtró esta
información a los medios de comunicación
lo hizo público inicialmente Y desde ahí
varios medios de comunicación empezaron
a hacer pública esta información
confidencial habló con cuatro de los
integrantes de este grupo de discordia
y dicen que pues el objetivo de Jack no
era tanto divulgar información
confidencial de Estados Unidos se supone
que pone en peligro Además la seguridad
de este país sino más compartirlo entre
entre amigos para tratar de Mostrar un
poco el poder que tenía al acceder esta
información pero pues eh hay que
recordar que jacera puede ser culpado
por diez años de cárcel por cada
documento filtrado es decir muchos años
de cárcel podría enfrentar Este joven
que ya está preso y que está siendo
procesado en este momento en
Massachusetts utilizar información
confidencial para presumir frente a los
amigos increíble vamos a cambiar de tema
porque el expresidente de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump compareció en Nueva York en
otro caso de corrupción que tiene su
contra este no es el de stormy Daniels
de qué se trata Cristóbal
Esta es la segunda vez que en
excavareciente Donald Trump va a la
corte de Manhattan a enfrentarse a una
indagatoria de la fiscal de Manhattan
por caso por un caso civil una demanda
de que esta fiscal general de Manhattan
tiene contra el expresidente Trump sus
tres hijos y la organización Trump por
haber orquestado un esquema de fraude
Financiero en Nueva York al tratar de
sobrevalorar sus activos para acceder a
grandes préstamos entre otros delitos
financieros la demanda es por 250
millones de dólares y iría a juicio a
partir el juicio empezaría entonces del
con esta demanda el 2 de octubre si es
que los abogados de Trump no logran
postergar aún más este juicio pero de en
caso de que la oficina del fiscal
general general de Manhattan pues eh los
Halle culpables después del juicio pues
Donald Trump no podría seguir ejerciendo
su derecho a hacer negocios en Nueva
York entre otras consecuencias